hello everyone my name is Luka and I'm  the winner of the main championships at  chess price powered by a good matter  Thank You Man for that you're the best  and in front of me you can see the board  which is huge and off of very good the  quality also the pieces are very very  nice with this smooth and soft green  bass also very heavy here you can see a  box like one of those from poker nights  and that's it  greetings from zabrze sheet which is a  city near zagreb capital of croatia like  a scene from the murder but ok and thank  you all for watching this is my leach s  name you're in juice if you want to add  me and play some games and that's it  thank you at the matter and good bye  everyone